fliegende autos hologramme und roboter
so stelle ich mir die zukunft vor
ein fliegendes taxi wird bereits seit
2017 in dubai getestet und augmented
reality ist an hologrammen schon
erstaunlich nah dran wie ich finde
aber wo bleiben die roboter
[Musik]
schnell präzise und stark
industrieroboter können extrem schwere
lasten tragen und diese auf die immer
gleiche art und weise bewegen
millimetergenau tausend mal
hintereinander
aber sie sind auch dumm jede einzelne
bewegung muss vorher von einem menschen
einprogrammiert werden
das ist kompliziert und dauert lange und
dann sind die maschinen auch noch blind
für ihre umgebung wird dem roboterarm
statt der autotür eine motorhaube
gegeben dann kracht's noch schlimmer ist
es wenn menschen in den weg der starken
motoren geraten
um das zu verhindern müssen
industrieroboter hinter sicherheits
wände oder in käfige gestellt werden
möglichst weit weg von uns menschen
aber es geht auch anders darf ich
vorstellen panda dieser kleine roboter
arm erinnert zwar noch an die großen
industrie roboter ist aber für den
umgang mit menschen entwickelt worden so
reagiert er zum beispiel mit hilfe von
sensoren in sekundenbruchteilen auch
widerstand das verleiht dem roboterarm
eine art tastsinn und gewährleistet eine
feinfühlige interaktion mit der
außenwelt wenn sich mensch und maschine
in die quere kommen dann stoppt die
maschine panda kann außerdem lernen mit
hilfe von künstlicher intelligenz muss
man einfach nur vormachen wie es geht
und der roboterarm macht es nach wenn es
nicht beim ersten mal klappt dann führt
man die aktion eben noch einmal vor wie
ein kind lernt panda durch wiederholung
und nachmachen und verbessert dadurch
nach und nach auch seine feinmotorik
hinzu kommt dass panda vergleichsweise
günstig ist
während sich nur große unternehmen
herkömmliche industrieroboter leisten
können kann panda auch von startups und
mittelständischen unternehmen eingesetzt
werden um zum beispiel produkte
herzustellen zu verarbeiten oder zu
verpacken
für den roboterarm haben die entwickler
professor sami haddadin simon haddadin
und sven kruse 2017 den deutschen
zukunftspreis erhalten
denn panda zeigt wie die zukunft der
roboter aussehen könnte an der seite von
uns menschen quasi als hilfe für
allerlei probleme der roboterarm wurde
zwar von studenten schon dazu gebracht
die spülmaschine einzuräumen aber mit
knapp einem meter ist der abend für die
allermeisten wohnungen doch etwas
sperrig hier kommt gar nie ins spiel
garmin ist quasi die nächste stufe des
erfolgreichen roboter abends nämlich der
passende mobile körper mit zwei panda
armen einem großen runden kopf und noch
mehr sensoren soll gaby in zukunft
kaffeekochen aufräumen oder eben auch
spülmaschinen ein und ausräumen
allerdings nicht für die leute die zu
faul sind das zu machen sondern für die
die es nicht mehr selber machen können
aber trotzdem noch selbstständig leben
wollen
mangel an pflegepersonal ist seit jahren
ein riesiges thema in deutschland und
ein günstiger aber vielseitiger roboter
könnte viele probleme lösen
er kann dinge vom boden aufheben an die
medizin erinnern und helfer kontaktieren
wenn mal etwas passieren sollte und mit
hilfe von künstlicher intelligenz können
quasi alle erdenklichen aufgaben schnell
erlernt werden
ganz auf menschliche hilfe wird man
natürlich nie verzichten können
garmin ist zum beispiel noch nicht in
der lage menschen zu tragen und
zwischenmenschlicher kontakt ist für
soziale wesen wie uns natürlich extrem
wichtig aber nach staubsaug roboter an
und lieferbar ist der pflegeroboter doch
nur der logische nächste schritt oder
mich interessiert eure meinung hier sehr
würdet ihr euch im haushalt von einem
roboter helfen lassen würde ihr euch im
alter von einem roboter pflegen lassen
und wenn ja wie stellt ihr euch die
zukunft mit robotern vor
schreibt eure kommentare gerne unten und
das video ich lese wie immer alle und
antworte auf möglichst viele davon
2017 habe ich beim fast forwards 1 video
wettbewerb in der kategorie vision den
ersten platz belegt und zwar mit meinem
video können wir unser gehirn hecken das
könnt ihr euch gerne hier anschauen
und was ich damit auch gewonnen habe ist
die möglichkeit mit dem deutschen
zukunftspreis zusammenzuarbeiten
ich durfte die gewinner des jahres 2017
hier vorstellen
wer die kandidaten für den deutschen
zukunftspreis 2018 sind das wird
übrigens sehr bald bekanntgegeben
dankeschön an den deutschen
zukunftspreis für die unterstützung bei
diesem video
vielen dank auch an fast dass ihr das
möglich gemacht habt und dann aus vielen
dank fürs zuschauen bleibt neugierig war
cedric